[Music]
hail
the barrel is empty yet would a bottle
be all right
[Music]
fine
i'll be right back
you said ale right
that's right am
my distributor sent me two new ales
one has a touch of huckleberry the other
one's more
the red ale do either of those
interesting
would it be acceptable
if i was to taste both ales
yeah that should be fine
all right two rails thank you
[Music]
all right this one
leave this one's huckleberry
this should be red
[Music]
i wanted to sample the two
new ales but these both
look and taste like the same
ale from
god's sakes my apologies be right back
oh sorry in the meantime while i'm
getting the other ales that i was
supposed to bring the first time around
would you like to look at the
dinner menus see if there's anything to
your liking
is that you joe and grantham
no but i get that a lot stop me
bother you all right it's okay
okay here with the two ales that i
mentioned earlier did you find anything
on the menu
i the slow cooker stew slow cooker stew
good choice i will now head into town
to buy the ingredients for the slow
cooker
i will be back before nightfall
i will wait he's not coming back before
nightfall
but don't worry it's worth the wait oh
oh it's good